jetzt mal ganz konkret gefragt woran
denkt ihr wenn ich atomkraft sage dann
fukushima gorleben und tschernobyl ganz
vielleicht noch an homer simpson aber
wir sind uns wahrscheinlich einig das
thema löst erst mal kein gutes gefühl
aus wir haben bilder im kopf von
katastrophenszenarien wegen eines super
gaus strahlende müll von dem keiner weiß
wohin damit
und von atombomben die uns alle
vernichten könnten dabei galt die
technologie mal als besonders sauber und
kann sie das vielleicht auch wieder
werden neue technologien versprechen
sicheren strom mit wenig co2 ausstoß und
atommüll der nicht für 100.000 sondern
nur für 300 jahre gelagert werden muss
aber reicht das aus um die atomkraft für
uns interessant zu machen
[Musik]
schauen wir uns als erstes einmal an wie
atomkraft überhaupt funktioniert um das
zu erklären habe ich mir hilfe vom kanal
tektas tisch geholt
es handelt sich hierbei um eine
kettenreaktion welche kontrolliert in
einem reaktor stattfindet und
kontrolliert im sinne von mindtake das
radio titel material auf einzelne
brennstäbe auch und kann diese je nach
einer gegend entfernen wo hinzufügen und
die eigentliche tat speichern läuft so
ab dass man schwere atome nimmt wie zum
beispiel uran 235 und dieses mit
neutronen beschießt dass man dahin kommt
schweren kam dessen rat seinen 35
absorbiert und wird somit instabil und
da ist diesen zustand mich mag sein dass
ich in leichter schräglage auf uns
selbst da ein freier energie in form von
strahlung welche dann das wasser erhitzt
und so weiter das wasser hilft wird
funktioniert das iphone carter im
prinzip wie ein kohlekraftwerk das wild
an zu kochen wird gasförmig eindruck
entsteht und diesel reicht eine
dampfturbine wird strom erzeugt es ist
im prinzip ein riesiger aroma
wasserkocher für die wissenschaft
das klingt ja alles erst mal ganz gut
aber was kann denn da schief gehen was
passiert wenn diese kettenreaktion außer
kontrolle gerät kommt es dann direkt zum
super-gau
es kann euch beruhigen ganz so
gefährlich ist atomenergie dann doch
nicht aber was ist ein super gau
überhaupt da steht erstmal für größter
anzunehmender unfall was das wort super
eigentlich überflüssig macht aber super
wird verwendet wenn bei einem
schwerwiegenden störfall die umwelt
kontaminiert wird die zwei wohl
bekanntesten fälle von super gaus in
tschernobyl und fukushima
tschernobyl ukraine 1986 ein geplanter
test steht an als die reaktor leistungen
aus ungeklärten gründen ab sagte der
chefingenieur anatoli die adloff lässt
eine unzulässig hohe zahl von
brennstäben entfernen um den reaktor zu
stabilisieren
dieser bleibt jedoch instabil und hätte
in diesem moment eigentlich abgeschaltet
werden müssen
mehrere waren anzeigen ignorierend lässt
er jedoch weitere brennstäbe entfernen
und leitet entgegen des rat seine
schicht leiters dem ursprünglich
geplanten test ein
da der zustand des reaktors immer noch
zu instabil für den sicheren betrieb war
gerät der test nach nur 36 sekunden
außer kontrolle
die reaktor leistung beginnt
unkontrolliert zu steigen und es kommt
zu zwei explosionen radioaktives
material wird hunderte kilometer weit in
die umwelt getragen 356.000 menschen
müssen ihre wohnungen und häuser
verlassen und sogar in zentraleuropa ist
der strahlungs anstieg deutlich messbar
zwar ist die ursache für den abfall der
reaktor leistung bis heute ungeklärt
jedoch hätte der reaktor von den
technikern abgeschaltet und so wieder
stabilisiert werden können
[Musik]
fukushima japan 2011 durch ein erdbeben
und einen anschließenden tsunami kommt
es zum ausfall der stromversorgung des
kraftwerks in den reaktoren 1 bis 4 gibt
es mehrere wasserstoff-explosionen als
mitarbeiter versuchen wollen den druck
zu reduzieren
doch auch brände sind die folge und
schon am ersten abend kommt es in drei
der vier reaktoren zu kernschmelzen
nur durch die nutzung von meerwasser
konnte noch schlimmeres verhindert
werden
doch das hat zur folge dass auch heute
acht jahre nach der katastrophe noch
verstrahltes wasser zurück ins meer
fließt 160.000 menschen mussten ihre
häuser verlassen und die krebsrate bei
jugendlichen aus der region wird 30-mal
höher eingeschätzt als im rest japans
während zu fukushima keine genauen
zahlen vorliegen und die regierung sogar
leugnet dass die erhöhten krebsraten
etwas mit dem unfall zu tun haben werden
die todesopfer von tschernobyl auf einen
vierstelligen bereich geschätzt weitere
6000 fälle von schilddrüsenkrebs wurden
registriert deren ungefähr 60 fällen zum
tod führte vor einem ähnlichen szenario
in europa fürchten sich atomgegner und
auszuschließen ist dass auch nicht von
129 aktiven atomkraftwerken in europa
wurde ein großteil vor über 25 jahren
gebaut gemessen an heutigen standards
ist die technologie von damals veraltet
die meisten sicherheitsmechanismen für
schwere unfälle erfordern menschlich
korrektes handeln um schlimmeres zu
verhindern
und manche reaktor modelle sind nicht
gegen alle möglichen unfall szenarien
gewappnet
der reaktor in fukushima beispielsweise
hatte ein system das den sicheren
einschluss von radioaktiven stoffen
gegen gewalteinwirkung von außen dienen
sollte
im falle einer kernschmelze wie sich
dies jedoch als problematisch da direkt
nach trockenlegung des kerns einen
druckablass notwendig ist der in diesem
falle zu den wasserstoff explosionen und
bränden geführt hat eine mögliche
verstrahlung des umlandes wird also bei
manchen szenarien einfach billigend in
kauf genommen meist werden bei diesen
alten reaktoren notfallmaßnahmen von
außerhalb der anlage benötigt anstatt
eingebaute sicherheitsmechanismen zu
nutzen
atomkraft katastrophen sind schrecklich
und haben zu vielen toten geführt
2013 hat die nase jedoch eine studie
veröffentlicht in der sie behauptet dass
atomkraft sogar 1,8 millionen tote
verhindert haben soll
wie kann das sein während atommüll zwar
hochgiftig ist lagern wie ihn dennoch
aktuell nur temporär weit unter der erde
im gegensatz dazu werden die giftstoffe
die bei fossilen brennstoffen wie kohle
entstehen einfach in die luft
ausgestoßen
das fördert lungenkrebs kreislauf
erkrankungen und chronische
lungenerkrankungen die oft leise und
schleichend zum tod oder auch nur zu
einem erschwerten leben führen das
max-planck-institut für chemie in mainz
kam zu dem ergebnis dass ein kompletter
verzicht von fossilen energieträgern
jährlich etwa 3,6 millionen menschen das
leben retten könnte fossile brennstoffe
machen laut den forschern etwa zwei
drittel der globalen luftverschmutzung
aus und nicht nur das kohlekraftwerke
strahlen mehr als atomkraftwerke klingt
im ersten moment total widersprüchlich
aber kohlekraftwerke verbrennen
radioaktives material aus der erde und
verteilen es in der luft ein
kernkraftwerk hingegen hat strenge
auflagen und gibt im normalbetrieb nur
sauberen wasserdampf an die umwelt ab
kein land hat mit luftverschmutzung so
ein großes problem wie china es hat sich
dort aktuell ganze elf neue
atomkraftwerke im bau befinden
die neuen technischen standards die dort
zum einsatz kommen unterscheiden sich
jedoch deutlich von den alten
kraftwerken wie sie hier bei uns zu
finden sind die unterschiedlichen
technik standards lassen sich grob in
vier generationen unterteilen
während aktuell nur kraftwerke der
ersten drei generationen in betrieb sind
arbeitet das generation for
international forum an der vierten
generation zu diesem forum wir heute
übrigens indirekt als teil der
europäischen atomgemeinschaft auch
deutschland die ziele sind klar
brennstoff soll effizienter genutzt
weniger atommüll produziert werden und
strenge standards bezüglich sicherheit
und der verbreitung von waffenfähigem
material müssen erfüllt werden es sollen
sichere systeme konzipiert werden die
allein durch die natur gesetze der
physik verhindern dass störungen
entstehen und nicht auf aktiven eingriff
des menschen angewiesen sind
im flüssigsalz reaktoren zum beispiel
liegt der kernbrennstoff in form von
geschmolzenem salz vor ein teil davon
befindet sich während des betriebs aber
in einem festen aggregatzustand und
verschließt so eine öffnung im boden des
reaktors kommt es nun zu einem
stromausfall und die temperatur erhöht
sich dann schmilzt das
als und läuft damit automatisch in
aufbewahrungs tanks in denen bedingt
durch die form und das fehlen bestimmte
eigenschaften keine kettenreaktion mehr
stattfinden kann
so kann ein sicherer zustand des
reaktors gewährleistet werden ohne dass
eine externe energiequelle oder das
eingreifen des personals nötig wäre
befürworter der atomkraft sehen sich
auch durch den jüngst veröffentlichten
15 grad bericht des weltklimarats der
vereinten nationen bestätigt fast alle
szenarien des berichts gehen davon aus
dass die weltweite atomstromproduktion
bis 2030 um mindestens 60 prozent
steigen muss um die geforderten 1,5 grad
einzuhalten
immerhin hat atomenergie seit 1976 64
gigatonnen an treibhausgasen verhindert
die sonst über fossile brennstoffe in
unsere atmosphäre gelangt wären
betrachtet man allein den co2 ausstoß
dann ist atomstrom ziemlich grün grüner
noch als wasserkraft und solarzellen
wäre da nicht der müll
allein in deutschland fallen jedes jahr
230 tonnen atommüll an
dieser muss nach aktuellen gesetzen bis
zu eine million jahre sicher vor der
biosphäre isoliert werden
denn nur ein millionstel gramm plutonium
einzuatmen erhöht die chance auf
lungenkrebs deutlich das problem der
richtige lagerort die bundes
gesellschaft für endlagerung hat es sich
als ziel gesetzt bis 2031 ein
dauerhaftes endlager für hoch
radioaktive abfälle zu finden
doch eine diskussion um die
grundsätzliche eignung von
gesteinsformationen für die endlagerung
und ein mangel an öffentlicher und
politische akzeptanz von atomenergie
erschweren die suche seit jahren
weltweit gibt es bis heute kein einziges
endlager nur zwischenlager juli sicher
alle eure kommentare und einige von euch
haben mich darum gebeten mir einmal
thorium reaktoren anzusehen thorium ist
ein stoff der durchaus als alternative
für uran in frage kommen würde
und zu zeiten des kalten kriegs waren
noch intensive forschungen auf diesem
gebiet statt
doch leider ließen sich aus uran bessere
atombomben bauen weshalb die forschungen
größtenteils eingestellt wurden
dabei lässt sich mit nur einer tonne
thorium so viel energie erzeugen wie mit
35 tonnen uran oder 4 millionen tonnen
kohle thorium kann besser recycelt
werden ist drei mal häufiger auf der
erde vorhanden als urahn und kann
außerdem nach unseren aktuellen
kenntnisstand nicht als nuklearwaffe
eingesetzt werden
des weiteren würde mit orion stadt uran
nur 0,6 prozent des aktuellen atommülls
anfallen
und dieser hätte auch eine deutlich
geringere halbwertszeit wir sprechen
hier von 300 jahren im vergleich zu
100.000 jahren das potenzial ist also
groß
doch bis jetzt gibt es noch keinen
funktionierenden thorium reaktor der
noch nötige sehr hohen forschungsaufwand
macht einen möglichen bau extrem teuer
thorium muss zwar nur deutlich kürzer
gelagert werden strahlt dafür aber auch
deutlich stärker eine neue form der
lagerung müsste gefunden werden
china plant zwar mit dem bau zweier
thorium reaktoren jedoch bleibt es
fragwürdig ob es sich lohnt so viel geld
und forschungsaufwand in eine
technologie zu stecken die wir auf dauer
loswerden wollen
denn ich denke über das langfristige
ziel sind wir uns alle einig weg von
fossilen brennstoffen und hin zu
erneuerbaren energien
aktuell können wir diese nur noch nicht
effizient genug speichern
und man ist sich uneinig ob
atomkraftwerke flexibel genug sind um
bei dunkelheit oder windstille schnell
einspringen zu können
größeres herunterregeln verkürzten
nämlich die lebensdauer
deshalb ist die frage an euch ist
atomkraft eine übergangslösung
ich finde dass atomstrom einen
schlechteren ruf rat als ihnen
eigentlich zustehen sollte die
unsichtbare gefahr der strahlung ist
einfach extrem angst einflößend und
nukleare waffen sind nach wie vor eine
gefahr für die gesamte menschheit hätte
man sich damals im kalten krieg für
thorium entschieden und von anfang an
die naturgesetze als
sicherheitsmaßnahmen genutzt dann sähe
die welt heute anders aus aber so wie es
jetzt steht sollten wir alles auf die
sonne setzen wir uns technisch erklärt
das so ziemlich jede kraftwerks arten
von nutzen also was viel kraft da einige
ausnahmen ihre eigentlichen energie
ursprung in der sonne hat
er sagt im prinzip dass die songs und
einfach richtig gemacht hat und klare
position der schlüssel ist auch mehr zu
meinem video denn das gedankenspiel
verdammt interessant und 3 was denkt ihr
ich weiß dass dieses thema extrem
umstritten ist deswegen freue ich mich
umso mehr auf eure wissenschaftlich
gestützten meinungen und friedvolle
diskussionen in den kommentaren
danke fürs zuschauen unterstützt uns
bitte aufhören wenn ihr mehr solcher
videos sehen wollt und ansonsten wie
immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]